ya se van conociendo los nombres de más
políticos franceses que se encaminan a
las elecciones presidenciales de abril
del próximo año
miles de personas apoyaron el polémico
ultraderechista eric se move candidato a
la elección presidencial francesa que
presentó en su primer mitin electoral el
que será su partido llamado reconquista
en la otra esquina más de 5000 personas
asistieron en parís al mitin del
candidato ni un popular jean luc
mélenchon quien presentó la constitución
de un parlamento de unión nacional y
también denunció la hipocresía lo que
llamó el y la cobardía del jefe de
estado emanuel macrón que sigue haciendo
campaña sin declararse oficialmente
candidato y por último el sábado la
derecha francesa eligió a valérie
pécresse como candidata a las
presidenciales luego de ganar las
primarias de los republicanos ya está
conmigo en el estudio philipp el
analista político internacional philip
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa muy buen día muy buenos
días feliz como leer entonces el
panorama electoral tras conocerse en los
nombres de estos candidatos a la
presidencia bueno le interese la
sorpresa de esta semana fue justamente
erigir para de derecha convencional
justamente de mar y pesca es que nadie
pensaba porque es una persona que se
había retirado del partido y ahora está
liderando justamente este partido
histórico que era el partido de de
gaulle y vemos que llega un momento
donde este partido histórico ha perdido
todo su base popular vemos a usted habló
de riquísimo que está reconquistando
esta base popular esta base popular que
la tienen en mano todavía
justamente al ala como se llama en el
que ya está liderando este partido y
está manteniéndose fuertemente entonces
ese momento de una pelea bastante fuerte
bastante interesante donde la gente
están tratando de reconquistar una vez
los jóvenes que va a ser complicado
sabemos que las elecciones no sabemos
quiénes van a votar ellos pueden cambiar
está la clase 2 cc más más es decir lo
sé
s&p plus es lo que es o extractora de
más o menos 5 y 6 que sabemos que van a
ir con bajo que todavía no se ha lanzado
que es normal es decir que los
presidentes en función normalmente se
lanzan en febrero entonces le pueden
hacer los ataques pero sabemos que más o
menos yo creo que va a depender de mí
con este momento cómo va pero va a ser
finales dónde va a ver justamente el
lanzamiento de la campaña pero peca es
justamente ese la la la la parte
ahorrará que acaba llegar porque primero
es una mujer nunca el pse partido había
dije una mujer es una mujer totalmente
preparada es decir que fue ministra de
presupuesto de haciendas ella dirige la
región más importante de europa en este
momento que es el mapa garrido house
entonces ahí para y para abajo va a ser
difícil atacar una mujer entonces
nosotros contra integrantes había sido
fácil ahora si le va a costar difícil y
no le puede reprochar justamente los
temas de gestiones pero la pelea si se
está se está llevando fuerte vemos que
el partido histórico socialista está en
quebrándose en este momento estamos
hablando de vamos a ver si va a lograr
un 5 por ciento fatídico que permite un
reembolso de campaña y dortmund el mundo
se está llevando mirando esto lo que
vemos es que se mueve es un fenómeno es
un fenómeno que puede subir
lastimosamente de orgullo porque vemos
que en el partido histórico de la
derecha
eligió a merino y pecas pero del otro
lado está el coach y coaching no se va a
ir es imposible porque acaba de ser
nombrado segundo del partido pero sus
electores sí y nos está costando dice
mucho y además que acaba de hacer pero
no acaba de hacer denuncias sobre la
campaña de américa es entonces él puede
recuperar una base de vectores de
derechas tradicional que se pueden ir
justamente los extremos es el miedo que
tenemos es decir que lo que vemos es que
anda subida fuerte los extremos es decir
que la campaña decimos parece un poquito
a la campaña que tenía make hace unos
años que se había retirado justamente de
del partido histórico del frente
nacional de mali lópez filipe hay con
todo este panorama entonces estamos
esperando que el presidente de mayor
makro me diga me lanzo a la reelección
presidencial que puede ser como está
diciendo usted final género de febrero
dando el panorama y digamos ya poniendo
también al presidente macro en esta
contienda electoral en esta campaña para
las elecciones presidenciales de abril
se puede pasar más chrome puede ser
reelecto o puede uno de estos candidatos
quitarle la presidencia manuel macrón
cuando ya oficializó su candidatura de
prueba quiere es decir que aparte de
américa es decir que desde muy se cree
el trono francés pero no tiene partido
que era una espalda entonces va a ser
complicado para él es decir que está
utilizando los mismos tips pero sin
tener un partido fuerte respaldándolo
marine le pen sabemos que no va a
alcanzar puede alcanzar la segunda
vuelta pero va a ser complicado y que
los franceses se voltean varias réplicas
y puede ser justamente el contrincante
fuerte justamente contra macro esta que
estamos mirando en este momento como la
reconquista del centro que va a ser la
parte importante es decir que vamos a
ver si los electores de izquierda no
creo que pasan a este lado es imposible
vamos a ver si continuar es pararme con
esto es quién va a dirigir las
elecciones los ateos la abstención en la
abstención va a ser un elemento muy
fuerte yo creo que puede haber una
atención muy alta en estas próximas
elecciones en la la crisis de la
pandemia que hay en este método eso no
puede favorecer tampoco entonces vamos a
ver cómo funciona esto pero yo la lo que
temo decir justamente que hay una
atención muy fuerte y eso justamente le
puede poner en peligro a maco porque los
selectores de pesca es la van a seguir
esos y sabemos que van a seguir que sean
primera una segunda vuelta pero en
primera o segunda vuelta los electores
de macon que son la mayoría en este
momento estamos hablando de casi 26%
25.9 entonces ahí hay que saber si se
van a levantar si dejan de poder sus
votos en las urnas ok philip ahora los
retos para el próximo presidente cómo va
a recibir francia que tiene que hacerse
cuál sería su prioridad digamos su
prioridad es base a la cohesión social
porque el problema es que este momento
los temas de extremos que en este
momento es decir de convivencia de la
población son complicados es decir que
en este momento son cinco candidatos de
extrema de izquierda a derecha pero
entonces esos cinco candidatos unos
pesan más que otros marine le pen que se
ha calmado un poquito de modo que empezó
a ponerle fuego sería de la derecha
tradicional que estaba yendo a ideas
extremas eso va a ser problema de decir
que en este momento hay un miedo de
cierto parte de la población justamente
con lo que está pasando es decir la
visión de francia está como se llama
totalmente sesgada piensa que están
abandonados tuvimos con los chalecos
amarillos estos esto esta franja perdida
que quieren regresar un poquito el
videoclip de campaña que hizo en youtube
de mujer a interesante regresando a
francia de los 65 es decir sí bueno es
decir que es esto es de la nostalgia de
un frac de una francia perdida que nunca
existió de todas maneras es decir que
esto es decir que mike france ya
critican es decir un poquito el tema de
su tilde de varios es ese es el peligro
de este momento es el peligro es decir
que aquí hay que calmar los ánimos la
gente tienen que pensar que va a ser la
lados elección de la elección número 12
a de la quinta república pero la 11a
voto al sufragio universal entonces
después de empezar a calmar es decir que
lo que necesitamos es que cuando va
avanza la campaña que empieza a detener
gente que empieza a reunirnos franceses
no empezar separados en este momento
vemos la separación lo vimos con el
debate de ese modo porque a las imágenes
que mostraron es decir que hubo peleas
fuertes sacaron la periodista que eso no
se había visto desde el románico pena es
decir que estamos regresando si a
francia de cómo se llama de no recuerdo
este político que se ha visto pulsado
estamos regresando a francia de pulgada
entonces eso es el peligro que estamos
mirando en este momento los ánimos están
muy muy muy como se llaman fuertes jazz
entonces hay que calmar calmar esto al
nivel de economía vamos bien decir que
al nivel de exportación bueno no vamos a
entrar la polémica de las ventas
militares pero ya francia de nuevo
estamos hablando de la venta que se hizo
representa al iva cosas imágenes es
decir que es una cosa tremenda y decir
que de nuevo la tecnología francesa está
acceda al nivel mundial el tema de
energía nuclear que se va a hablar si
centrales hay muchos temas de economía
que se tienen que tomar